et la chronique culture après le cinéma
on va s'intéresser à la musique vous
allez voir à l'humour également avec les
invités d'aurelliia de Bic bons soir oui
bonsoir wilfri donc ce soir nous
recevons monsieur lune bonsoir et Michel
bocage donc vous êtes le directeur du
festival Jazz à toute heure donc on y
reviendra tout à l'heure vous nous
expliquerez vos choix de de sélection
votre programmation originale cette
année monsieur lun on s'intéresse à vous
ce soir parce que vous donc vous êtes un
artiste de la nouvelle scène France
tout à fait voilà et vous avez créé donc
un spectacle pour enfants un compte
musical donc qui s'intitule l'histoire
incroyable de Gaston et lucroable hisire
de Gast l'incroyable histoire de Gaston
et Lucy et que justement vous présentz
vendredi et samedi à la Maison de
l'Environnement de Manil amau et
l'originalité de ce spectacle c'est
qu'en fait vous avez mis en place en
parallèle des ateliers écriture chanson
avec des enfants de manilé Hau et l'idée
donc c'était qu'ils imaginent et
écrivent en fait la suite suite compte
exactement alors expliquez-nous
justement le le principe de ces
ateliersà bah disons que déjà
l'incroyable histoire de gastronie c'est
un livre disque qui a été adapté en
spectacle que je tourne maintenant
depuis 2 ans et effectivement depuis que
je me suis mis au jeune public comme on
dit
euh souvent je je travaille dans les
écoles pour écrire des chansons pour
aborder euh le système d'écriture la
chanson les syllabes les rimes et Cera
alors qu'est-ce que vous leur faites
faire aux enfants parce que c'est des
classes de ouais là c'est des classes de
CE2 bah là simplement moi je leur en
général je leur apporte un canva musical
à peu près établi et à partir de ce
canva on on on imagine d'abord une
histoire et puis après je leur apprends
comme il y a pas vraiment de règle pour
écrire une chanson c'est assez empirique
on sait pas trop d'où ça vient est-ce
que la musique vient d'abord est-ce que
les les les les par d' question qu'on se
pose tous hein d'ailleurs moi tout vient
à la fois là pour le coup pour que ça
soit un peu plus facile en général
j'arri avec des mélodies préétablie et à
partir de ces mélodies préétablies on on
écrit d'abord l'histoire et à partir de
cette histoire on écrit une chanson qui
doit faire avancer narrativement euh la
la suite de l'histoire de Gaston Lucy
sachant que Gaston Lucy c'est dans un
monde où tout le monde est moche il y a
de beau c'est ça le principe on reçoit
ce soir monsieur lune sur le plateau et
j'ai quand même cette question à vous
poser monsieur lune pourquoi ça vient
d'ù alors Monsieur lune ça vient parce
que j'étais avec des potes fallait faire
un concert et j'avais trouvé et c'était
il y a bien 13 ans maintenant et fallait
trouver un nom donc j'avais fait une
liste et c'est Monsieur lune qui est
resté une fois que tous mes potes
c'était un groupe sont partis je me suis
dit que comme j'avais une fan ma
grand-mère je suis dit que j'allais j'ai
gardé le nom et puis comme j'ai une tête
un peu ronde j'ai gardé le nom et puis
voilà ça fait un peu musique pour
enfants même si la plupart du temps
depuis 10 ans j'ai fait 5 albums qui
sont des des chansons pour adultes et la
question du jour qu'on m'a demandé de
vous poser bien évidemment est-ce que
vous êtes marié avec Madame Soleil voilà
elle un peu in d'Illes je crois qu'elle
est décédée d'ailleurs bah écoutez
c'était pour plomber l'ambiance merci
non je suis pas marié avec Madame Soleil
voilà alors pour avoir un un aperçu du
du spectacle on va regarder un extrait
donc qui a été tourné il y a quelques
années mais donc évidemment on Nura pas
la suite C en fait l'extrait vous allez
voir c'est c'est vrai que c'est une
formule on est en trio alors que
maintenant comme c'est un succès
complètement international maintenant on
est à 5 sur scène avec une chanteuse
alors que là j'étais juste avec deux
camarades musiciens alors on va regarder
tout de suite d'abord il faut un début
original il était une
fois un monde quelque part dans la
galaxie où il y avait un
soleil ça c'est normal mais dans ce
soleil il y avait le petit homme du
soleil qui
en et puis je vais le laisser se
présenter tout seul après tout oh mince
je suis encore à la Bour il est déjà
5h59 il faut que j'aille
bosser ça y est il est 6h il faut que je
me réveille il y a le travail qui
m'attend la nuit a déjà sommeil dans une
heure c'est mon tour allumé le
soleil doit voir le jour chaque matin
c'est par la les
homes les habitants deille que l'on app
les beau vilins sont toujours gay le
bonheur est leur quotidien ils
s'entendent excessivement bien et se
font des politesses à longueur de
journée tous les beau vilains trouvent
que Gaston est moche il on trouvé un
métier c'est assis dans sa cage en
venant le voir les habitants de bville
se rappellent qu'ils sont beau on est
beau on est bien habillé on est alors la
vie est belle on le sait parce que
garçon est là sa tête de pioche écrasé
par une
pelle alors Monsieur lune ce spectacle
comme vous l'avez indiqué traite des des
beaux et des moches hein ce sont vos
termes c'est ça donc finalement le thème
principal c'est c'est quoi la différence
bah c'est la différence à disons
qu'effectivement on trouvait déjà
marrant de dans un monde où tout le
monde est beau qui est de moche moi je
trouvais ça rigolo et puis je voulais
surtout que ça soit un petit peu
custique je voulais pas juste faire un
compte musical pour les gamins en
faisant Piou Piou tout va bien il y a
des petites fleurs et des petits oiseaux
moi en écrivant ce compte avec un
camarade on a imagine ça comme un film
un peu à la Pixar c'estd avec beaucoup
de second degré beaucoup de distance
effectivement c'est assez cruel et puis
après c'est peut-être aux enfants ou au
parents d'expliquer s'il y a une morale
la différence on n'est pas pareil mais
c'est pas parce qu'on est pas pareil que
on va pas vivre mais dans dans
l'histoire c'est vrai que c'est c'est
assez dur c'est Gaston il est moche tous
les mecs le trouvent moche et grâce au
fait qu'il soit moche eux se trouvent
encore plus beau ah oui ça valorise
d'accord alors finalement est-ce que on
peut passer des messages est-ce que
c'est plus facile de passer des messages
au travers de de la ch moi je sais pas
si je passe un message en écrivant après
le message ce que je vous disais c'est
c'est plus les gens qui interprètent moi
ce que j'ai voulu ce que ce qu'on a
voulu dire nous c'est raconter une
histoire au point de vue de la narration
de l'intrigue et cetera au point de vue
des chansons j'ai pas du tout imaginé ça
comme quelque chose pour des enfants
mais je me suis d'abord fait plaisir à
moi et les messages après je pense
qu'ils viennent après il y en a
peut-être mais c'est plutôt à la
personne qui écoute d'interpréter les
messages plutôt qu'à moi de dire j'ai
voulu faire passer une grande idée moi
je fais j'ai juste écrire des histoires
et et écrire des chansons c'est tout et
puisque l'on parle musique chanson et
que avec notre autre invité tout à
l'heure nous parlerons jazz également
nous sommes allés vous poser cette
question dans les rues de sa quant en
ieline aujourd'hui est-il important que
vos enfants écoute de la musique et puis
surtout quel type de musique ils
écoutent oh bah oui c'est important
n'importe quelle musique je dirais la
musique c'est oui oui oui moi j'ai eu
des enfants qui ont écouté la musique
très tôt il dicton la musique ai des
meurs paraîil donc autant qu'il commence
de bonheur la musique pour enfants tout
simplement pour ne pas les les agresser
trop rapidement et oui je pense que
c'est important des
contines des contines
ou du rap pourquoi pas oui c'est
important qu'ils écoutent tout types de
musique musique classique musique
moderne de tout oui c'est très important
qu'ils écoutent de la musique déjà moi
j'en écoute alors bon c'est c'est c'est
la musique g c'est c'est sympa quoi
c'est bien ça ça libère l'esprit ça ça
rangua c'est c'est c'est joli c'est
beau du rap pour les enfants et pourquoi
pas du jazz alors absolument d'ailleurs
nous organisons quatre concerts pour les
enfants nous accueons 2000 élèves des
écoles du parc naturel régional pour
quatre concerts pour les scolaires donc
je suis absolument d'accord avec
Monsieur lune il faut faire écouter de
la musique aux enfants j'aurais juste un
truc à dire pour moi il y a la musique
pour enfants doit plaire aux adultes en
revanche la musique peut-être pour
adultes ne peut pas plaire aux enfants
mais en faisant de la musique c'est on
fait de la musique ça doit marcher quoi
qu'il arrive il y a pas de la musique
pour enfants c'est de la musique a de la
bonne ou de la mauvaise musique que les
enfants il faut aussi éveiller leur leur
oreilles justement à des musiques qui
sont pas forcément musique pour enfants
écrite pour eux des musiques peut-être
plus d'adultes ou du jazz on pensait
c'est important aussi après c'est
inventer des formats peut-être un peu
différents point de vue temps mais c'est
surtout de faire la musique qui
j'imagine quand vous programmez pour les
enfants ça vous plaît aussi à vous en
priorité absolument c'est une règle on
programme que ce qu'on aime voilà et
pour en revenir alors au aux ateliers
d'écriture donc vous avez avec ces
enfants imaginé une suite à votre
spectacle est-ce que l'imaginaire des
enfants est quel regard vous portez sur
leur imaginaire est-ce qu'il est
finalement si différent de celui des
adultes moi je pense qu'ils ont surtout
cet âge là ils ont 8 ans ils sont assez
libres ils ont plein d'idées après c'est
justement les idées là moi j'ai ce que
j'ai remarqué que c'est souvent les
meilleures idées sont considérées par
eux-mêmes pas toujours comme les
meilleurs génér il a une espèce de
d'État ah tu as dit ça tiens c'est une
bêtise alors que finalement moi avec mon
œ extérieur je me dis mais c'est génial
vous êtes enfin au contraire c'est ça
qui est super et après c'est justement
des idées on en a tous plein mais
maintenant faut les reconnaître et
mettre le doigt dessus après c'est à moi
d'essayer de les orienter pour voir où
est-ce qu'il faut aller dans quelle
direction moi mon rôle est un rôle de
directeur artistique là-dedans mais
après c'est de trouver l'équilibre entre
moi ce que j'apporte et eux ce qu'ils
apportent c'est quand même le plus
important pour que on a l'impression
d'être utile pour eux et de leur faire
découvrir un nouveau monde un nouveau
métier une nouvelle vie qui qui est
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus accessible que
ce qu'on peut bien nous faire croire en
général la musique est-ce qu'il y a
moins de barrière que pourrai se se
donner les adultes oui à 8 ans ils ont
beaucoup moins pudique ils sont pas
encore c'est à partir du 6e 5e ù là ça
commence à être beaucoup plus rigide
beaucoup plus cruel donc là c'est vrai
que c'est vachement bien c'est super de
bosser avec eux parce qu'ils sont un peu
fous bon c'est dur pour canaliser quand
il y a un gamin d'un coup mais moi comme
je suis un peu un peu tout fou comme ça
on s'entend bien et pour découvrir votre
univers il faudra se rendre sur ce
festival à tout bout Dechamp rappelle
les dates Aurélia oui donc vendredi et
samedi à la Maison de l'Environnement
plus particulièrement samedi pour le
tout public puisque le vendredi c'est
réservé au voilà les scolaires qui
viendront voir le leurs copains sur
scène tout à fait merci beaucoup
monsieur lune mais je vous en prie euh
alors on va partir de de la musique
quelques instants pour rejoindre un
atelier de danse donc c'est de la danse
celtique en vue du bal la musique
celtique aussi c'est de la musique aussi
en effet mais le but est d'apprendre la
gig et et autres danses en vue du bal
celtique qui aura lieu ce vendredi au
scarabé on regarde les
images il ne manquait que du vert dans
le cadre de la saint-patrique où l'on
célèbre la culture celtique l'espace a
céser de la verrière a proposé un
atelier de danse irlandaise un moyen de
découvrir de nouvelles chorégraphies
j'aime bien la danse celle tuaime bien
le les danses en général et j'avais
envie d'apprendre et c'était l'occasion
on a globalement abandonné dans notre
culture tout ce qui
était danse populaire même musique
populaire on entend plus rien de de
musique folklorique et autrees et là ça
fait du bien de revenir aux racines en
fait si elle reste festive la danse
irlandaise requiert tout de même
certaines exigences c'est structuré mais
pas énormément et donc ça laisse
beaucoup de place à un peu d'imagination
et de disons de isation personnelle une
danse complète faut compter entre 20 et
25 minutes et on s'arrête une minute
donc c'est quand mêmez sportif après
cette initiation les participants sont
invités à danser l du concert celtique
du groupe B ce vendredi au scarabé à la
verrière